officials say the disaster in Houston
will get worse over the next few days
hurricane Harvey is still a tropical
storm and it's causing catastrophic
flooding much of the country's
fourth-largest city is under water the
numbers are staggering the storm is
knocked out power to more than a quarter
million homes and businesses it's blamed
for at least two deaths thousands of
people have been rescued from the
floodwaters it's not known how many
people are still trapped Norah O'Donnell
is outside the city's main shelter set
up at the George R Brown Convention
Center in downtown Houston Norah good
morning hey good morning to you Margaret
that's right Harvey has already dropped
an estimated 11 trillion gallons of
water on Texas and the rain is not going
to stop for days it rained all last
night it's been raining all this morning
forecasters say some areas end up
getting 50 inches of rain we talked with
Red Cross officials here at the
Convention Center who say the number of
evacuate in this facility alone jumped
to about 2500 over night there was just
they say they can only they were only
prepared for about 1200 the FEMA
administrator administrative predicts
more than 30,000 people will need
temporary shelter the Army Corps of
Engineers started a controlled release
of water from to flood reservoirs
overnight now they're trying to protect
downtown Houston making sure that the
reservoirs don't collapse but the
release of water will make flooding
worse in some neighborhoods we're
talking about a massive rescue effort
that is continuing this morning and the
number of flood affected areas is rising